this year's new york international auto
show came to a close at the weekend as
every year the venue was the jacob
javits convention center in manhattan in
recent years the show's been enjoying
growing attention from industry insiders
and the media
well the New York show is a pretty major
show for the US but obviously it's not
that big compared to what you would see
on a scale around the world so let's say
we just were in Geneva Geneva's kind of
the equivalent of a fashion show a
runway fashion show i would say New York
it's a little bit like a ready-to-wear
collection maybe you're not seeing the
world debuts at least crazy insane
supercars like you see in Geneva but you
do see a lot of very good solid debuts
of cars that are going to sell really
well in the u.s. like SUVs some sports
cars as well but you're not going to see
the really crazy stuff that you see at
some of the European shows porcher
presented its McCann compact SUV with a
new engine
I'm Mekons Invid stand week ago we have
introduced a turbocharged 4-cylinder
version of the Macan with 252 horsepower
zero to 100 in 6.1 seconds fret not it's
four cylinders packed quite a punch
bajas this makan resembles more powerful
Porsche models in both looks and specs
the new Prius Prime sees Toyota focusing
on eco-friendly mobility this
second-generation plug-in hybrid
reflects the manufacturers close
attention to customer feedback on its
predecessor it's it's a huge vehicle for
us not necessarily in a lot of volume
but it really adds a great halo over the
total brand it adds a lot of innovation
and improvements and technology and
safety into the prius family the prius
prime comes with a new larger 8.8
kilowatt-hour lithium-ion battery which
extends its electric range
flying the flag for domestic brands was
Lincoln showcasing a huge new SUV the
Navigator concept well America is always
associated with big cars and SUVs I
think part of that is because there's so
much space in America you know we have
wide open roads it's kind of the idea of
the American dream people have families
that have a lot of things you want a lot
of space when you travel so typically a
show in the u.s. like the new york auto
show is the place where they unveil cars
like this audi showed off its powerful
new r8 spyder convertible
Armand bunderson we've given it a
beautiful 10 cylinder engine so it's
great fun to drive with the roof down
the sound is music to your ears you
don't need a radio just run ish the
sound of those 10 cylinders concerned
intend to linda's out
with 397 kilowatts of power and 540
newton meters of torque it makes the
dash to 100 km/h in just 3.6 seconds the
two-seater convertible is quite a beauty
and also a state of the art piece of
engineering with plenty of aluminium and
carbon and less steel it weighs in at
just 1612 kilograms Mercedes is another
brand deeply committed to performance it
showcased a new SUV a new GLC Kupe and
several new products from its in-house
pimping parlour OMG one of the most
significant debuts here at the new york
auto show is for mercedes-benz they have
unveiled four world premieres of AMG
variants across their different model
lineup the u.s. is a very important
market for the AMG brand statistics say
that twenty-seven percent of all AMG
models that are sold are sold here in
the US so obviously Mercedes is going
very aggressively after the US market
the world car of the year awards are
also always part of the new york auto
show 73 automotive journalists from
around the world make up the jury there
are awards in four categories and an
overall winner
this year's performance car title went
to the Audi r8
the mazda mx5 really cleaned up winning
both the design award and the top prize
world car of the year we have a strong
philosophy to develop our products and
technology and design has come together
and deliver driving fun and brand
essence of a service driving is a lien
core value and we strive to deliver this
core value to all the customer and that
this award endorses our efforts so we're
very happy that away from the awards
mazda also presented its mx-5 RF with a
retractable hardtop the two-seater
roadster is the latest incarnation of
mazda's legendary sports car
fans of the Opel Astra can now indulge
in the youngest member of the compact
class station wagon generation the
sports tourer continues a tradition that
began with the very first cadet in the
early 1960s over a fifth of the 24
million cadets and Astros sold were
wagons the new Astra sports tourer is
the 10th generation of opals popular
family car
soares I'm yards on the Opel cadet wagon
was a revolution on its launch in 1963
explains our car man Lionel compact
vehicle with an enormous trunk and
originally called the caravan not is it
sealed as a side seats were likewise
completely new these ones look more like
camping chairs but technology has moved
on since then and today between ten and
twelve percent of production costs for a
new model go on the engineering and
construction of the seats to fill us in
wayanad has brought along an expert
Andrew Louis man hello swung by more Dan
of modern seats are the product of a lot
of development work and money where
exactly do they cost so much you go to
Darvish fastest unless was underdone
Madeleine's it's not advances or toya
there fishsticks the driver the biggest
factor is safety explains the expert
from opal by an area in which seats have
become hugely important is for
inshaallah shove the most i like to
illustrate it with the example of a car
doing a crash test he says which
everyone has seen on TV finding the
impact releases a massive amount of
energy and its the sink that helps to
ensure the occupants stays put so that
the airbag advantages and all those
other features can do their job back de
cuarto and early the shrimper colors at
email from tenanken what does it also
has to be a lightweight construction
owner because of co2 emissions in field
plus these days people expect ergonomic
comfortable seats so all that combined
pushes up the costs to target leakage
top 10 meters it's off to harm universe
Muslim comfort butan diesel can mega
logotype to a nom de crossing and on the
visual front to the Astra sports tourer
sets itself apart from the competition
thanks to the divided c-pillar and
sloping roofline
the front boasts an all-new double
chrome bar carrying the Opel lightning
bolt which merges into the LED matrix
headlights the nice and wide tail gate
opens and closes automatically with a
little kick of the foot del I or paratha
measuring 4 meters seventy long the new
Astra sports tourer has a trunk capacity
of 1613 litres 80 more than in the
previous version as in the sedan the
sports tourer also comes with an
extensive range of assists and online
multimedia and navigation systems
in earnest their spots the sports Torah
is now bigger on the inside reports my
knowledge there's more head room at the
front and more space for the second row
of seats to the rear bench is now split
in three with a 40 20 40 split that also
enables you to load long car going over
the middle seat the 160 horsepower
diesel engine may have a displacement of
only one point six liters but has the
sound of a far bigger machine fires have
a choice of five gasoline engines with
outputs of up to 147 kilowatts and for
diesel units with up to 118 kilowatts
the lowest price configuration costs
18,000 260 euros in Germany the version
we checked out sells for just over
29,000 euros well start a census among
the many features are traffic sign
recognition emergency braking of blind
spot alert and a lengthy persist plus
prolific smart phone connectivity
ergonomic seats and new high torque and
low consumption diesel engines teva and
assess the Opel Astra sports tourer as a
sound alternative to similar models from
Volkswagen Skoda and Ford plus the
Astor's the only car its class to come
with LED matrix lights adding a boost
the nighttime safety this car is 1 meter
74 wide and 4 meters 42 long and belongs
to the compact class the best sellers in
the segment come from the big players
the Ford Focus toyota corolla and
volkswagen golf but this compact car is
made by the automotive division of
japan's fuji heavy industries in other
words it's the new subaru impreza
mean come on the compact class is as
competitive as it gets as our car
reviewer Android one new trend we're
seeing in the segment is manufacturers
seeking to combine more engine versions
of vehicles with wheel drive and copy of
oil and here client Subaru and says
anything you can do we can pursue now
the car maker does have a long tradition
in all-wheel drive and the Impreza
represents a nice price rival to the
Gulf and is only available with or wheel
drive we tried out the top-of-the-line
edition of the employer with xenon
lights rear view camera and adaptive
cruise control the two-liter boxer
engine generates 110 kilowatts of power
all in all it will cost you twenty five
thousand three hundred and fifty euros
in Germany
lets me run some tests on z1 and Ray
really appreciates is how the test car
pulls away so swiftly so if you're out
and about on city streets with this 2
liter engine DIMP razor you needn't
worry about slowing other road users
down but Subaru wouldn't be the world's
biggest producer of all-wheel drive
passenger cars if it didn't have some
very special setup Subaru calls its
symmetrical all-wheel drive whereas most
car makers in the compact segment have
systems that only engage the rear wheels
when the front wheels slip the Impreza
boasts permanent 5050 wheel drive
subash which and in addition to all
wheel drive explains andre subaru is
also a fan of boxer engines which then
lower the car center of gravity
elementary physics will tell you that
this in turn impress handling if the
weight will hire up there'd be a bigger
tendency to roll when driving around
bends what sauce is done in an event
megan rising about egged so the
appraisers handling benefits big-time
here there's no oversteer and no
understeer target your curve steer into
it and just drive one ZT Korver it's
perfect length fetish allestree signs or
to optimize in purely visual terms the
interior seems on the Spartan side but
our test car did have a leather steering
wheel and a multifunctional display
above the infotainment system a rear
axle used to power the car often means
less cargo space but with the rear bench
up the Impreza is certainly a match for
the class leader the Gulf
as all as for the rest of the interior
at first Andrew found the seats a little
too soft and the steering wheel is on
the skinny side he likes a bit more to
hold on to me from cancer fellatio this
since umaga garden as a hobo definition
Havana missing Mohammed reality ravenous
beasts in graphic avira while other
manufacturers reserved all-wheel drive
for higher price segments you can get it
here for as little as 18 thousand six
hundred euros the subaru impreza is a
car for drivers with their very own
style or for people who don't live in
the city
mine facet overall and Roy says the
Impreza is an idea option if you live up
in the hills with frequent snow and
other challenging road conditions with
its all-wheel expertise this is
something of an insider tip especially
with regard to the price tag for
anything by dem pies
it's a Fiat a Fiat 500 but not the one
you may be used to our car reviewer and
Manuel puts it through its paces our
bird a thief methanol this isn't the
regular fiat 500e says but its finger
brother the 500x a mini SUV crossover
it's built on the same platform as it's
American cousin from the Fiat Chrysler
family the jeep renegade negate the 500x
is quite a bit bigger than the 570
centimeters longer and almost 20 wider
there is a choice of three diesel and to
gasoline engines ranging from 70 to 104
kilowatts of output
they're often there's not much room in
the back reckon to manual other SUVs are
certainly more spacious but it's okay
for short trips especially in town
English that one fit and despite its
off-road look the 500x is meant to be a
city car doesn't auto the rear lights
are just like those on the regular 500
the trunk capacity ranges from 245 to
1000 liters
but enough of the stats let's get moving
options for the top models include four
wheel drive and automatic in one's
unpack our test car is a 103 kilowatts
or 140 horsepower 2-liter diesel
floretta 300 newton meters of torque
will put the front axle in quite a spin
or both axles in the four-by-four model
and off you go you my fevers gone hut
one done gets up to these four votes the
starting price in Germany for the 500x
is just under seventeen thousand euros
this test car with the biggest diesel
engine cost close to 27,000
thus far bag is from in in manuals
opinion the suspension is definitely too
hard they're marketing the 500x as an
SUV if you actually went off-road in it
you would probably get a proper shaking
of it it goes from 0 to 100 km/h in nine
point eight seconds top speed is 190
minimal on the interior sports rather a
lot of plastic but the cockpit is well
thought out all the controls are easy to
find but at least in this version the
controls are shiny so if you've just
creamed your hands I have sticky fingers
you will certainly leave your mark and
that's not pretty music the end I in
claim that affecting your finger have to
happen walk talk that thing I pluck it
off and this is not sure the other
standard sure start and stop costs an
extra three hundred and fifty euros with
this edition its standard in the cross
and cross plus models
Allison Alan dear all in all the 500x
certainly has its strengths some
weaknesses one good thing is the design
in contrast of the 500l which looks like
a stretched blood of chewing gum and
really does not look nice the 500x does
have some of the charm of the original
500 after Nam elephant will not take on
fresh with image present or even give
isn't show a vinyl roof abundant chrome
trim the finest leather and wood inlays
it must be a luxury car from the early
1970s the Jaguar XJ kupe with its v12
engine is quintessentially English
blending elegance and sportiness into
one at the 1973 london motor show the
british luxury brand rolled out a 4c
coupe a version of the XJ launched five
years before the series familiar
straight-6 engine was standard with a
v12 as a glorious option
since it was made in very small
production runs the noble cat is rarely
seen on the open road these days or even
at vintage car meets
smart before my Yin Zell trashed of
hamburg's garage 11 dealership
appreciates the sleek lines of the older
car and the 12-cylinder engines
interaction with the automatic
transmission he says it's nothing like
the conventional power trains of the
time but he can hardly put it into words
jo is 5.3 liter v12 was a legend among
car engines famous for its even
acceleration and silky smooth running
but among mechanics the car was more
infamous anymore dog yen Santos says the
engine compartment looks more like a
snake pit he's got no problem with the
engine itself if it can run dependably
for some 200,000 kilometres without an
overall but he doesn't like
disassembling the entire intake duct
just to fix the air conditioning
maintenance is very time-consuming even
if parts are relatively easy to find but
otherwise he says car is nothing to fear
for the modded chats canals jaguar
unveiled the XJ co-pay in 1973 they
didn't appear in showrooms until two
years later it targeted the
individualist who could dispense with
four doors in favor of two but not with
the luxury of the jaguar sedan it was
based on
Yin's describes it as a car for the
connoisseur capable of high speed so
without matching aerodynamic designs the
grill is a bit small for his taste but
he likes the way his jag glides along at
160 km/h it has no b-pillar so driving
on country highways with the windows
down is heavenly
the imitation leather vinyl roof is
typical of the 1970s
and having two fuel tank filler next
near the rear windshield is typical of
Jaguar
aside from the rear doors the coupe a
has all the amenities of the sedan among
them a large trunk for that holiday on
the French Riviera and space for four
people the interior offers the
obligatory luxury ambience with fine
wood paneling around the dash and
British Connolly leather on the doors
and seats in the mid 1970s and xj12 can
play cost the equivalent of about
twenty-five thousand euros making it
Jaguars most expensive model yen says it
was a top car for a top prize at the
time it costs about the same as a small
town house by plunking down two hundred
thousand euros for a car today just as
far beyond the reach of ordinary mortals
now as it was then there's in a castle
we are going to learn acting notes on
most every little valise uttermost parts
are available for the XJ but it may take
some intensive searching to find a 12
cylinder Kupe in good condition and it
could easily cost the same 25 thousand
euros it did new
gen surg ghost explains that prices for
the XJ Kupe are climbing and they're
much higher than for a sedan from the
time very few specimens are left the
body the last to be designed by Sir
William Lyons and the powertrain are
unique all this makes for the cars
attraction this is our smart the launch
of the next generation Jaguar coupe ad 2
by 2 xjs in 1975 spelled the demise of
the x JQ pay
but hardcore Jaguar connoisseur's
insists the XJS can't measure up to the
elegance of an XJ co-pay one of the most
alluring automotive creations of the 70s
you